[Music]
district 9 follow-up starts out looking
like the exact same movie reading they
must have passed a law that all movies
need to place the inception noise
somewhere in order to get passed by the
MPAA that's racist unnecessary wagon
wheels Space Station design all of these
candles are an orgy of evidence that
this was a terribly unsafe Orphanage
exposition delivered by a children's
book this movie is like Gattaca with
more robots main character introductory
shaving scene cliche 2154 Los Angeles is
an Arizona Bay yet look I understand
production budgets can be limiting and
bleak and destitute future is a good way
to go to avoid having to create too much
in the way of futuristic props but this
is 2154 so this truck is roughly a
hundred and fifty years old I'm not sure
all the routine maintenance in the world
would make this possible 22nd century
Americans have allowed the word queue
into their vocabulary listen about hair
products muslin max who has dealt with
authority figures all his life tries to
joke with two serious robot cops and
expects it to go well DMV parole office
elevation heart rate detected this robot
can detect heart rate elevations but not
graffiti artists writing on his face no
I am okay thank you are you being
sarcastic and/or obvious I'm thinking
frustrating by the book everything is
black and white robot parole officers
can detect sarcasm set decorator had an
obvious conflict with the director
regarding the definition of enough
graffiti the robotics company in the
Year 2154 uses humans to build its
robots don't car factories in the year
2014 already use robots to build cars
also what is this job you construct
robot suits and then stick them in some
sort of radioactive chamber for what the
plot later how do you coordinate an
operation like this with thousands of
people knowing about it and not get
caught also since we find out these
ships basically get shot down on the
survivors are just deported why would
anyone try going on this trip I know
you're desperate but seems like the odds
of surviving this bulk bit are
non-existent
these ships are approaching Elysium
pretty quickly but activate screwed up
thankfully agent Kruger is never more
than a few seconds away from a rocket
launcher
wait Elysium has all this technology and
they don't have anything to defend
themselves they rely on people on earth
to shoot missiles through the atmosphere
and hope that
books also even if that was the best
defense system you have you're basically
gonna have missiles coming straight at
you if they miss they could hit the damn
Elysium okay so the third missile misses
where's the fourth missile that Krueger
shot haha modern societal commentary
painted on a prop
send them to deportation get them off
this habitat Oh Elysium is America I get
it
also how does deportation Elysium have
such an overcrowded prison system you
put lots of people on a ship and you
send them back where they came from or
are illegal successful trips to Elysium
so commonplace that they constantly have
hundreds of people coming in by the hour
look either you go in there right now
I'll find someone who will this movie is
like Upton Sinclair's the jungle with
more robots also this is game theory
with yourself right I mean you know if
you go in there and move the palette
then the doors going to close and you'll
be trapped but if you refuse you'll be
fired and you might have to steal cars
again and maybe go back to jail if
you're caught I don't know it seems like
a simple choice to me also what did the
foreman think was going to happen if he
went in there and move the palette is
there any other conceivable possible
outcome other than this that would make
this for man anything short of the devil
himself by forcing max in there this is
basically murder right movie rips off
the main character gets trapped inside a
radiation chamber thing from both Star
Trek twos do these death machines not
have an off button this robot is a dick
to max hey we're only 23 minutes into
this thing better show the audience that
opening flashback again in case they
forgot it this movie is like Silkwood
with more robots at 1500 hours just
today you shot down two shot do you call
her into your office immediately after
that happen but decided to wait a full
day to yell at her for it your mandate
is to deal with illegals quietly
honestly you should have no conflict
here there's so much money on Elysium
simple defense system shouldn't be that
difficult to create even nonviolent ones
tell me something
president pastel do you have children oh
come on you know the answer to that just
get to your condescending point already
I understand that it is not the the
fashion to think and to act as actively
other actors will not think it is the
fashion to act as Jodie Foster does in
this movie damn you guys Kipp JJ
Abrams's a hard time for his lens flares
but I nominate a new target Neill
Blomkamp's graffiti this isn't Elysium
we can't just heal her it's amazing that
hospitals down on earth haven't figured
out Elysium magic healing machine and
charge whatever the market will bear for
it max goes to see some dude named
spider but unfortunately has to travel
through the motocross scene from Batman
and Robin to get there
is your favorite what cookin here once
guy turn to page 45 of bad guy cliche
dialog the sorry I can't hear you please
repeat your grumbling because it gets me
off page underground criminal area has
flashing fluorescence cliche this can be
your ticket up there one last job for me
you earn your way out spider plays the
pronoun game with a dash of unnecessary
vagaries so that max has to ask what the
hell he's talking about
you are here to persuade me to renew all
my nine contract actually I think he's
hoping to persuade you to stop doing
that thing with your head and your voice
every time you talk so great banding
fuchsia
Foster and thickener you're welcome
Carlisle inexplicably has one of these
arrow pointing the weight of my dick
tattoos on his forehead in flesh color
and Martha went to DNA now you fit in a
new one right up until they shoot you
down in your shuttle with missiles now
there's more graffiti in this future
than would be possible if literally all
human life on Earth had taken up
graffiti as a hobby is this the only way
to upload and download data in the
future
to and from your head because it seems
like in this day and age the criminals
expect the data to be in your head so
why not throw them off by putting your
important data on a protective flash
drive or encrypted cloud of some sort
also Carlisle conveniently uploads
crucial information to his brain just
hours before max plans to hijack the
contents of his brain futuristic Tech's
capable watches use dot matrix graphics
discount Cylons all of this future
technology tells you everything except
when something likely danger is a shot
and lodges into your ship victus isn't
growing a prawn arm in this scene ivory
commissioned two of your
agents completely confidentially it
cause she do that so fast as soon as she
heard about Carlisle she immediately got
on the phone with Kruger even at the
mere press of a button these guys
would've had to drop what they're doing
get on a ship and fly right over to
Kruger in just a few seconds why did he
shoot regular bullets at the second
robot instead of shooting that staggered
explosion grenade thing he used on the
first robot it was really effective it's
amazing to me that a very important
person's personal spaceship crashed and
now we've got criminals in illegal
mercenaries all firing bullets and bombs
and not even a couple of robot cops have
shown up yet
amazing exploding discs have a
substantial enough delay on them so that
people can still shoot at you before
they explode also these human seeking
death discs are a fantastically
effective weapon but Kruger doesn't use
them anymore after this and this is the
moment when you realize the director has
more cool futuristic weapon ideas than
the story can actually sustain I mean
there should be no fugitives no crime no
anything in this future if the
authorities have access to an arsenal of
gizmos that would make Batman jealous
the one guy who never messes around when
killing people decides to do so when it
comes to killing max seriously he's got
a forcefield shoot max ends up shooting
this guy anyway but how many problems
could the elysian soul on their end by
having a defense mechanism like this
citizen has suffered catastrophic blood
loss leading to cardiac arrest
time of death 1745 later we find out
Elysium has some sort of failsafe in
place for citizens on the ground who
need medical care but they never once
jettison a healing bed straight to
Carlisle when he gets shot why did the
Elysium satellites stay on dead Carlisle
instead of following the running away
max wouldn't they be able to help Kruger
find him
Anasuya ex machina how did they lose him
because Delacorte is an idiot who can't
properly task her all-seeing satellites
that's why at bus I think you better
come look at this I think you better
come look at this cliche this is a
record of what we picked up being
transferred between kala and the
criminal sir what if that organic brain
data can be intercepted wirelessly then
why did they have to jack into
Carlisle's brain in the first place why
is Delacour concerned about Kruger
leaving Max's brain intact if she can
just fish that doubt over interstellar
Wi-Fi also why didn't oh everyone on
Elysium see this data getting
transferred especially since their
entire focus is on citizen and danger
Carlyle wouldn't a transmission of this
sort be picked up by their satellites
now just eat the fondant so that it the
girl Krueger waits a long-ass time in
the hunt for max before releasing badass
drones that would have been really
helpful
earlier max stumbles to the hospital
just in time to see for a pass by the
window
the nurses sick child from earlier comes
in really handy when she needs a bunch
of medical equipment in her home to
secretly treat max most convenient sick
child ever made friends with Potamus
okay stop Matt Damon interrupts a little
girl during her spoken word adaptation
of We Bought a Zoo max bitches out and
doesn't take the sick kid with him
but fortunately Kruger comes behind him
and takes the kid and the woman with him
so that max will have a second chance to
help save them scouting ship just
happens to be flying down the very
street max is on just after he leaves
phrase house yes ciao this flight
jamming seems like it might come in
handy during unauthorized flights to
Elysium oh well how come plugging into
Max's head only shows the stolen
encrypted data and not his orphanage
memories or masturbation fantasies I
don't even know why you try sending
people up there man they just get shot
down character points out minor plot
hole once an attempt by the film to gain
forgiveness for it
unleash sir
like a look at the hey you already use
that cliche Jim is fat so they'd only
traveled one block since kidnapping
Freund Mathilde at whole thing with max
getting plugged in and arguing with
spider and the walk he made to and from
that location and all Krueger and
company managed to get away was one
block everyone we're rooting for
survives this deadly spacecraft crash
and the bad guys do to ensure you have a
fundraiser to attend Jodie Foster is
equal parts 1990s George Clooney and
kick-ass Nicolas Cage in this movie it
is the weirdest performance by a
legendary actress I have ever seen
using your leukemic child to break an
inner this is the second break-in we've
seen so far in these ultra futuristic
Elysium homes but not once has the house
set off alarms are shut down or have
robot servants try and stop intruders
which is apparently what so many lesions
fear everyday Wow the bad guys had
electric stun guns this whole time - I
guess they would have used him before
then also had all those other ridiculous
futuristic weapons to go through first
but this could have been effective
during that whole fist fight a few
moments ago that cost the crash in the
first place right how long before you
can download and turn the system online
not long man fact this should take
roughly the amount of time it took to
get into him but I'm sure it will take
longer so that max could escape no one
who is literally paid to watch the
Elysium sky for a living notices this
unauthorized ship coming into its
airspace even after the computer
acknowledges an unlicensed craft
approaching also the ship comes in like
it expected the land with no problem we
don't see anyone inside the ship saying
wow this is so amazing that we got
through no problem when nearly every
other ship we've sent up here gets shot
down
there's no explanation for this smoke
break Elysium is taken to allow this
kind of breach but he's fine the grenade
melted his entire fucking head this is
such a ridiculously magic machine that
it's amazing not one of these Elysium
people have tried to make a profit with
them down on earth
victus isn't turning into a prawn in
this scene yeah let's leave the super
important fugitive in a super-strong
mech suit completely unguarded and alone
in a room with two nurses cracked mirror
reflection is a reflection of psychos
mind cliche apparently you can just lock
an elysian citizen into a small room in
the computerized keep Elysium safe at
all cost system won't allow you to
unlock the door looks like everyone here
is doing a bang-up job of preventing
ships from entering the airspace oh wait
you threaded eyes - there was nothing
stopping me from killing them before but
yeah now kill them we now bring you the
bad guy deletes the killing process so
that the nice people can be saved
portion of this movie sudden mysterious
migraine gives Kruger a chance to catch
up so now that's possible in this movie
but we never see it again
so who cares yeah rather than just
slicing your neck real quick and getting
you out of the way I'd rather simply pin
you on the floor temporarily you must
burn aid has ridiculous explosion delay
while max figures out how to get out of
this another break-in and is anyone ever
at home when this goes down let's form a
society where none of the plebs can get
in now write a single line of code that
gives someone the option to change that
that's science fiction hero has to
sacrifice himself to save the world
cliche counter story I'd tell the whole
story back to you again but I only have
like five more hours before the
president and his men finally break down
this door somehow all the sick
Earthlings heard about the rebooting of
Elysium and the dispatched medical
crafts and come running together at the
same time skin follow
[Music]
okay I was I went to UMass I wasn't
insulting you well I thought you were so
now you gotta buy me dinner maybe you
can shoot someone and then you have to
see me professionally I'll stab someone
in the heart with a nice pic if it's
read in it with you
[Music]
I understand that it is not the fashion
to think and to act as I do I understand
that perfectly because deep down in
places you don't talk about it parties
you want me on that wall you need me on
that wall if we listen we can hear God's
plan God's plan
alright let me tell you about your God's
plan there is no God there is no God it
bring down the bone saw get up you're
not good I don't look at me I love you
what gentlemen we can rebuild him we
have the technology we have the
capability to make the world's first
Bionic man
not right there do you know how easy
this is for me do you have any good idea
how easy this is a joke yeah and I'm
sorry you can't do this I really am
because I wouldn't have to consider ever
watch you stumble around and get up
you see Confederated products is a
multi-level direct wholesaling company
which means we don't just sell the
products ourselves no sir Yuri Bob we
recruit and manage teams that work under
us now Irina and I started eight months
ago and already we're pulling in 50,000
a year in revenues yes but they're
working he everything keeps going any
idea why you're stealing from your new
friends are dead
don't want to build a dream doing